What are your thoughts about taking methylene blue for someone with chronic
Lyme and co-infections in brain fog? Yeah, that's not contraindicated for Lyme disease. You can
certainly take that. If a person has chronic Lyme or chronic autoimmune disease, if you're going to
be adding supplements, my recommendation is to add them one at a time because sometimes if you
look at my autoimmune course, you'll see that you don't want to be taking things. If you have an
autoimmune disease, you don't want to be taking things that are immune stimulators because you
already have antibodies to self-tissue. If you're going to take things that are immune stimulators,
well, you're basically stimulated in your immune system to kill that which you have antibodies
against which if it is self-tissue, you're stimulated in your immune system to kill your own
tissue. Betheline blue is not an immune stimulator. It's typically thought of as an immune
modulator, but just because something is typically thought of as something safe, it doesn't mean that
you won't react differently to it. Everybody's a little bit different. Everybody has a different
physiology and your body can act differently towards things. So I'd always recommend that you
test things. The only way is you can know that your test is at least the most accurate you can be
as to do things one at a time. So you're going to add a supplement. Don't make any other drastic changes
in your diet or your lifestyle or your habits or anything while you're testing that supplement. So
you can try it for a couple days. Did it make you feel worse? No. Did it make you feel better? Well,
I haven't figured that one out yet, but you're really testing. Does that make you feel worse?
By taking something, it makes you feel worse. That it's quite possible that it's stimulating your
immune system and that's not a good thing. Now, the issue that I see with people with chronic
Lyme, many times they've been told incorrect things like, oh, you're just having a Herk's reaction.
That's actually good. You're having a lot of die-off of the Lyme and Co-infections.
And that's most the time when that is happening. That's not what's taking place. That if they do
have antibodies in self-tissue and they're taking some protocol that's making symptoms worse,
more often than not. It's actually stimulating their immune system and they're destroying self-tissues
so they're making their immune. They're making their autoimmune disease worse. They're actually
worsening their condition. Many things are blamed on symptoms that are blamed on a Herk's reaction,
and that's just not true.